Wellness now there's a word you don't
hear every day it means exactly what you
might think it means the opposite of
illness it's a movement that is catching
on all over the country among doctors
nurses and others concerned with medical
care
now that's Dan rather's 60 Minutes
report on Wellness that was from
1979. Wow our next guest says it was a
turning point that brought Wellness
culture into the mainstream Christy
Harrison is her name she's a registered
dietitian she writes about that moment
in her new book The Wellness trap break
free from diet culture disinformation
and dubious diagnoses like that and find
your true well-being it shines a light
on the potential dark side of the
wellness industry and she joins us this
morning as part of our Wellness week
series with conversations dedicated to
the topic Christy we welcome you I got a
big kick out of your section on juices
and cleansing because you said they can
actually do more harm than good and the
reason why this struck me about many
years ago when it first started I lived
in Greenwich Connecticut a group of
women would Gather in a parking lot
Christie on a Sunday for the person to
come and deliver our little juice boxes
I mean that's how bad it was where
shivering it didn't matter if it was
raining or something because you got get
the juice after a while it just seems so
silly to me and you write in your book
people think that they were Superior if
they could tolerate the really terrible
tasting greens as opposed to the sweet
ones but I actually thought it was
healthy to do and you say what about
that yeah I say you don't need it you
know it's not healthy I think it often
has really unintended side effects it
can cause a lot of digestive distress
especially if you already have a
sensitive system and you know these
juices are being promoted as cure-alls
right we see celery juice is kind of the
big Trend now it's being promoted as you
know cure-all for everything autoimmune
conditions digestive disorders anything
under the sun and you know often can
just exacerbate some of the issues that
it's purporting to cure so if you see a
tip on social media for healthy eating
other than clicking the bio and saying
is this person a registered you know
what are they how do you evaluate it how
do you know if it's worth following for
you yeah I think that's a great you know
first step is to look into the
credentials of the person recommending
it then you can look at what other
reputable sources say you know are they
are they citing Journal stuff studies
you know look at the studies and I mean
not everybody has time for this right
but if they you know have a link to a
study or something just check it out and
see does that actually say you know
support what the person is saying it
supports
um looking at what other reputable
sources say about the same topic you
know there's valid scientific debate
about certain ideas but then there's
also people really spinning out like
very early stage research or no research
at all into these wild recommendations
and Gail mentioned juicing you also
share your thoughts on fasting which
everybody has an opinion on oh yeah yeah
your thoughts I don't recommend it I
don't think it's a good idea
um you know I think a lot of people try
it thinking it's going to be better for
their health or they're that they're
going to lose weight but research has
actually found that people don't lose
more weight when they're fasting they
end up reverting to Baseline you know
Weight Wise and also in terms of health
markers and oftentimes it can make
people feel really obsessive and
disordered about food you know but you
seem to debunk many things that we're
raised to believe you said listen
exercise good nutrition all of that is
really great but you said that's not the
most important thing what what really
matters to keep to have a healthy
population you say is what yeah I even
say supplements you should see all the
supplements I say take you think that's
a waste of time too yeah so the
supplement industry is largely
unregulated there's really no testing
for safety or efficacy but think before
things go to market and so you can get
things that are just you know
potentially really harmful but in terms
of population well-being the actual the
most important thing is the social
determinants of health and those are
factors like so like socioeconomic
status Access to Health Care access to
clean air clean water you know stable
housing and things like that you know so
at the population level that actually
accounts for 70 percent of population
well-being and then that that other 30
percent you know and these are like
things we can control so not not
including genetics but the other 30 is
Health behaviors but of that only 10 is
actually food and exercise combined the
other 20 is things like you know alcohol
smoking Sexual Health practices but this
was this is personal for you Christy I
mean things happen in your own life that
you really drill down on this industry
yeah I did I got really disordered in my
relationship with food I I went studied
abroad my junior year of college and
gained a little bit of weight started on
a diet and it quickly spiraled into
disordered eating and then I started
having a lot of health problems as a
result and seeking out care for those
problems and nobody could figure out
what was going on for me and it turned
out that a lot of what I was doing in
the name of Wellness was actually
causing and exacerbating these problems
so you say don't concentrate on Wellness
people concentrate on well-being yeah
what do you mean so well-being is a more
Global sort of accounting for
um you know what goes on in our minds
and our bodies and our relationships
with other people you know so it's
social emotional connections with other
people economic well-being mental health
which I think is so important and you
know it's really left out of the
conversation on Wellness I think a lot
of practices that people do in the name
of Wellness can actually harm people's
mental health and focus purely on the
physical and really taking them away
from these overall aspects of well-being
all right Chrissy Harrison thank you
very much I mean you've laid out a lot
of interesting theories that you and
research for us to follow and really
good it really made me question a lot of
things that I do thank you thank you the
wellness trap is on sale now if you or
someone you know is seeking Mental
Health Resources you can call the
National Alliance on Mental Illness help
helpline that's at
1-800-950-6264 or you can text the
helpline to 62640